hi everyone I'm Laura Ingram this is the
Ingram angle great to have you with us
Biden's birthday collapse what that's
the focus of tonight's
[Music]
angle today it's 81 candles for our 46th
president that's quite a personal
accomplishment I must say well the stars
of stage and Screen have traditionally
loved celebrating Democrat presidents on
their
birthdays happy
birthday to you
Happy
Birthday Mr
President happy
birthday to
you everybody happy
birthday Biden was 19 and a half years
old when that took place but this year
the affair was a little more subdued
even his Pals and the Press are having
trouble finding something to celebrate
Joe Biden is celebrating his 81st first
birthday and I'm sure he would wish for
different polling on his birthday one of
the things that the president cannot
change is the fact that he is 81 years
old Happy Birthday Mr President you
can't magically become younger President
Biden is 81 today he will continue to be
older brilliant analysis he's going to
continue to age wow but these people see
the writing on the wall don't they the
voters including many of Biden's old
constituents are in full-blown Revolt is
numbers are dropping faster than his
words in mids sentence now less than a
year before election day the just
released NBC poll has Biden approval
numbers at a record low of 40% and among
young people I almost fell over when I
saw this he's at 31% on the economy his
number is
38 then young voters give him an abysmal
20% on foreign policy that's his
handling of the Israel Hamas war of
course now Trump is up 4% among young
voters and 2% overall so wait a second
this must be a oneoff this can't this
can't be a TR well hardly this confirms
the trends we've been seeing now for a
while and a new Harvard heris poll just
released shows the birthday boy is in
just as much trouble against Trump down
by seven points although for some reason
Biden's approval number in that same
survey is oddly jumping a little bit to
45 but inside the poll on specific
questions it's more bad news for Biden
Americans fears and frustrations about
crime wow that's clear 63% of those
surveyed believe gun ownership is
important to be able to protect yourself
against attacks and 83% want to crack
down on
shoplifters all right let's face it try
as they might it's just impossible to
spin these numbers the data guys have
pretty much just given up this by the
way is the lowest we have measured his
job approval rating since he became
president the last time a Democratic
candidate did this poorly amongst voters
under the age of 35 was before either of
us were actually
registered of course Biden's most
truculent supporters did try their best
to see the bright side on a slew of bad
Biden polls are these poll results and
you can comment on that part of a Biden
pattern um not to be overreacted to when
you look at where he ends up I think
we're all a little skeptical of some of
the polling the most interesting finding
of the poll which actually uh everyone
should look at is that 77% of Democratic
primary voters support the president in
that poll that's the his highest number
yet oh my gosh okay that analysis is
just sad and as usual it's totally out
of touch it turns out the bad news for
the globalists here in the United States
is also being reflected as bad news for
the globalists around the world
Argentina saw a shock win for the
populist candidate Javier M and the
anti-immigration conservative populist
movements are growing all across Europe
in France in Sweden Germany and Spain
more on that with Victor Davis Hansen
coming up but the bottom line is clear
in all of this the old Clinton Bush
consensus on globalization that demanded
free trade the free movement of people
and Perpetual foreign intervention it's
just collapsing everywhere that
narrative is not working it just doesn't
work for the average person it was a
policy of the elites by the elites and
for the elites it failed everyone else
so it's time to go back to real
democracy and give the voters what they
want and that's the angle hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else